I can't think of any more human activity
than conducting science experiment think
about it what do kids do young kids kids
that can barely walk what are they doing
they're turning over rocks they're
plucking petals off of rows they're
they're exploring their environment
through experimentation that's what we
do as human beings and we do that more
thoroughly and better than any other
species on earth that we have yet
encountered it helps to have opposable
thumbs of course and really huge heads
with gray matter doing the processing we
explore our environment more than we are
compelled to utter poetry when we're
toddlers we start doing that later
before that happens every child is a
scientist and so when I think of science
I think of a truly human activity
something fundamental to a DNA something
that drives curiosity they go together
the act of being curious and the act of
wanting to do the experiment when you
conduct science it is the natural world
that is the ultimate decider on what is
true and what is not so what that means
is if I discover a scientific idea
surely someone else would have
discovered the same idea had I not done
so whereas look at van Gogh's Starry
Night if he didn't paint starry night
nobody is going to paint starry night so
in that regard the arts are more
individual to the creative person then a
scientific idea is to the one who comes
up with it but nonetheless they are both
human activities in the early days of
robots people said oh let's build a
robot and what's the first thought you
make a robot look like a human and do
human things
that's so 1950s we are so past that all
right the Hubble Space Telescope is a
robot we send it commands it turns
one-way images the universe sends the
image back to me it doesn't look like a
human being
it doesn't smile it doesn't have arms
and legs so this notion that a robot
might turn on us and what that's not the
robot's we're creating Skynet coming
online and achieving consciousness okay
keep doing the movies they're fun but I
live in the real world the real world
that simply knocked the robots who we're
making and even if we did they would
just be really good computers of things
and they give me access to information
actually I already have access to
information it's on my smart phone a few
fingertips away from all gathered
knowledge of the human species on earth
it's called the Internet I'm already
there people talk about plugging it into
your head I don't need to neuro
mechanically plug it into my head with a
new brain USB port it's right here at my
fingertips already thank you